warum frist die jungen damen ist luca
und herzlich willkommen hier meine damen
und herren zu einer neuen episode von
lukas reagiert ich dass es ein format
womit meine zuschauer bei twitter videos
einsenden können wie die dumm sind und
glaubt mir diesen dummen
ich war nämlich mal wieder auf twitter
unterwegs und habe mir einige von diesen
videos angeschaut und darauf reagieren
wir heute das war schon das komplette
intro wollte dieses huhn nicht kennt
meine damen und herren das ist das
horror wohl und jedes mal war heißt es
eigentlich auch hund ist ja auch egal
aber auf jeden fall immer wenn ich sage
hey schickte video san luca reagiert
kommt immer ein video von dem horror
hohen also horror hohen mal schauen was
es heute zu melden hat kannst es
schaffen zu erraten welche farbe ich
jetzt tanzen werde
sie soll ich denn erraten welche farbe
du tanzt wie kann man überhaupt farben
tanzen
bist du dumm wie soll ich erkennen
welche farbe du getan hast ich meine wir
können uns das ganze einfach nochmal
anschauen
vor
da habe ich denn
zur auswahl weiß rot blau oder gelb
[Musik]
rot blau oder gelb bist du komplett
bescheuert ich habe keine ahnung wie man
farben tanzt oder wie man errät welche
farbe da gerade getanzt wurde aber ich
würde sagen rot und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem nächsten video
meine damen und herren da sehen wir
wieder das komplette talent der ligue un
jesus seine person die alle meine
entchen mit dem fuß spielt das kriege
ich glaube ich auch noch hin
[Musik]
ok selbst
die person jeder gerade eingeblendet
gesehen habt sind bts das sind kate
hobbykünstler aus dem asiatischen raum
und da wurde mir in dem tweet luca
könntest du mal wieder auftrieb ob
reagieren genauer gesagt auf bts also
auf diese truppe da war das mal wieder
möchte meine damen und herren also ich
habe ja schon mal auf hiphop reagiert
[Musik]
das weiß ich jetzt allerdings noch mal
machen soll das kam ja auch echt mega
gut bei euch an das video über eine
millionen aufrufe ändern lasse man like
da und bei 15.000 normale summe würde
ich sagen also wir haben in einigen der
letzten videos über 100000 likes
geknackt was ja mega krass ist 50.000
leicht zeigen mir auf jeden fall hey
mach mal wieder hier ein bisschen was
das auch folge während des videos fixe
ich hier gerade das kabel meines mikros
wird mir auf jeden fall zeigen halo
carrera gts aber wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten video
ihren mann oder frau keine ahnung was du
bist doch gar nicht fordern stehen
aufbau nicht so ganz bisschen was im
dorf als die mund aufmachen dann nicht
gerne draußen bin schade das ist ganz
europa geile geschadet und den inneren
kern
a
weiter brauchen wir uns dieses video gar
nicht anschauen weil das wichtigste gut
gesagt schauen dass luca video
macht ihr auch gerade oder nicht
schreibt man die kommentare ob ihr
gerade das video schaut ja was macht ihr
sonst gerade
hast du gerade deo auf eine schaukel
gesprüht warum sprüht man dem auf
irgendwas drauf was
du hast nicht wirklich noch ein
feuerzeug dabei oder
warum
kommt mal eine community auf solche
komplett geisteskranken ideen einfach
eine schaukel mit deo einzusprühen und
diese dann anzuzünden und das video geht
sogar noch weiter
also ich stelle mir das gerade so vor
was bei denen den köpfen losging david
da war irgendwie die vielleicht zwei
jungs oder drei jungs so freundes mäßig
verabredet haben zu denken was machen
wir es heute abend hey lass war zum
spielplatz war der schauplatz sind und
dem mitnehmen und feiertagen haben den
flammenwerfer all das sind super idee
alpakas sind einfach die verdammt
nochmal süßesten tiere der welt ich weiß
allerdings trotzdem nicht was ich bei
diesem video gerade verstörender fand ob
es einerseits das alpaka war aus dem
anderen alpaka am po gerochen hat oder
ob es die situation war das dieses mal
packer dem anprobe wochen wurde dann
gegen das andere alpaca gegen läuft also
aber alpakas sind hammer süß schreib mir
meine kommentare was euer lieblings
tierfreunde also ich spiele halt immer
mehr mit dem gedanken mir irgendwie ein
hund zuzulegen aber sondern packe als
haustiere eigentlich auch ganz geil
danke an der stelle für deinen support
allerdings ganz gute werbung an der
stelle freunde ich hoffe ihr kennt
mittlerweile alle meine shop adresse wie
ich bereits schon häufig gesagt habe
freunden am ersten sechs kommen neues
merchants also in zwei wochen kommen
neue klamotten in meinem shop es wird
lädt erste sechste 15 uhr schreibt euch
überall hin wo man hin schreiben kann
[Musik]
das ist echt traurig wie sich tanzen so
die letzten jahrzehnte entwickelt hat
früher haben sich frauen sondern kleid
angezogen
die herren haben den anzug angezogen
dann sind wir auf irgend den ball
gegangen die haben ihre tanzschritte
vorgeführt und heutzutage gehen leute
einfach mit jogginghose und schlabber
shirt uns im klub und dass das genau das
mache ich gut lukas friedl ist gerade
das beste buch auf dieser welt und
dieses teams erstmal danke schön dass
ihr das buch gefällt er mich habe selber
noch einige exemplare hier rumstehen
allerdings finde ich leicht verstören
dass du deinen kissen freddy genannt
hast
also ich selbst habe hier auch einige
kissen an der wand hängen aber ich
glaube jetzt einen namen
jedes einzelne kassen
hahahahaha wieder ein witz rausgehauen
weyermann wieder voll lustig hrt hat
muss gehen
du kommst mir ein bisschen bekannt vor
aber ich weiß nicht genau woher ich dich
kenne okay du hast einfach über sonnen
alles schwarz weiß gemacht so das kann
ja jeder machen
es wäre schon einmal cool wenn du mir
noch ein tipp geben könnte es also mal
schauen ob ich dich jetzt erkenne
ja ich weiß was für ein vollidiot
ja jetzt wird
wie lange brauchst du um von dieser
scheiße rutsche zu rutschen
ja wir grüßen
[Musik]
da habe ich den ganzen tag
hier sehen sie das größte opfer des
planeten
jaha lustig lukas stinker des ruhig sein
buch mit dem 1
er macht denn so was
[Musik]
mein absolutes highlight von diesem
video warum ist es immer noch cool wenn
leute den hier machen
juckt es irgendwen von euch wer da rein
[Musik]
ja okay ich bin ein opfer
du hast dich aus dem fenster gelehnt und
hast richtig laut geschrien
danke für deine bruno ganz im ernst
freunde der werbe video aber erst 16
wird es fanden die idee schon was jetzt
kommt freunde das war einem livestream
von mir den ich auf instagram gemacht
habe beide erfolgt nur auf instagram
dienstag ran da kommste luca und jule
und ich haben uns basketball zugeworfen
und seht einfach selbst
ja hat leicht wehgetan
wtf alter die hatten schon zu hause als
haustier einen igel als haustier in der
tat zweier hunde so übertrieben
freundlich spielt mit dem gedanken
irgendwie hin zu holen ich weiß nicht ob
er bei mir glücklich wäre also natürlich
gibt es eine option so wenn man gegend
unterwegs ist und ich bin ja relativ
viel unterwegs leider dass man den hund
dann irgendwie im hundehotel abgibt und
dann kann er dort mit anderen hunden
spielen und dann kann er da auch mal für
eine woche sein und hat er auch seinen
spaß da wird auch den aufgepasst wer
bekommt essen und trinken was für
allerdings von rund holen würde wäre auf
jeden fall ein golden retriever also so
ein oder als hoch ein
oder so ein das sind schon
hardt süße tiere aber ja ich weiß nicht
wenn ich mein hund holen würde würde ich
ihn aber auf jeden fall lohnen schreibt
wendy kommentare bilden noch wisse war
danke für deine aufmunternden und
motivierenden worte
[Gelächter]
da hat mir jemand ein gedicht
geschrieben luca hat sich eine pizza
gekauft hinter ihm ist ein dieb der
gerne raucht er springt mitschülern aus
seinem versteck und verprügelt luca der
fällt in den dreck in der die brennt mit
der pizza weg sie ist belegt mit käse
und speck
das ist besser als goethe allein auf der
einen seite ist es umweltverschmutzung
weil du diese pappkarton in den garten
in die natur schmeißt und auf der
anderen seite ist es es verschwendung
und du brichst mir mein herz aber gut
dass du das video eingesetzt hat und
zwar wollte ich immer ganz kurz über
pizza reden wie ihr wisst habe ich
letztes jahr eine pizza rausgebracht
dies ein hunderttausendfacher ausführung
gab und die war nach einigen stunden
ausverkauft es wird dieses jahr noch
eine zweite pizza geben
jetzt habe ich gesagt wir planen gerade
als ich hoffe dass es dieses jahr noch
klappt aber wir planen gerade und es
wird auf jeden fall wieder mit
wie der erst sechste vielleicht nehme
ich würde sagen gleich als cooles video
warum frist das ist ein produkt mit dem
man sich west nicht die zähne wäscht
schwester mit deinen körper frist liebe
hat meine pizza werden sie dann
hoffentlich irgendwann bald mal
rauskommt an der stelle wird das heutige
video ist allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich hatte einfach mega
mega rock mal wieder auf einige videos
von euch zu reagieren falls ihr nicht
auf twitter folgt und wenn ihr mir auch
mal videos einsenden wollen können jetzt
unter dem hashtag nun reagiert machen
twitter und instagram und snapshot und
alles steht er in der beschreibung die
zu beginn gesagt freunde bei 50.000
likes werde ich demnächst mal wieder auf
pts reagieren schreibt morgenkommentar
auf was ich mir auch mal reagieren soll
wie alt seid ihr habt ihr ein alter